Canada will continue to stand with
Ukraine with whatever it takes as long
as it takes today I can announce that we
will provide 500 million dollars in new
funding for military assistance in
addition today I'm announcing that
Canada will be part of the multinational
efforts to train fighter pilots and to
maintain and support Ukraine's fighter
jet program leveraging Canadian
expertise in these areas we will also be
contributing to the multinational
leopard tank maintenance initiative
we will provide an additional 288 aim 7
missiles which will support Ukraine in
its efforts to defend Ukrainian skies
and from existing funds we will provide
10 000 rounds of 105 millimeter
ammunition to the Ukraine Security
Forces
while we provide military aid we also
take strong actions on sanctions and on
economic measures
we've all seen the devastation caused by
the collapse of the dam of the kakova
hydroelectric power plant in Carson
region this week this was a direct
consequence of Russia's war and it is
devastating for thousands upon thousands
of people
to help with the response today I'm
announcing 10 million dollars in new
funding and will be redirecting 37.5
million dollars of Canada's currently
allocated humanitarian assistance for
Ukraine to respond to this flood hello
Demir thank you again for your welcome
today you and the Ukrainian people are
an inspiration Canada for Canadians and
to the world this is a consequential
moment for Ukraine or did it also is a
consequential moment for the work you're
fighting for your country and for values
like democracy Freedom respect dignity
but in fighting for Ukraine you're also
fighting for the future of us all Canada
will continue to stand shoulder to
shoulder with Ukraine and so will
democracies around the world thank you
my friend for all that you do thank you